we're trying to solve
one of humanity's biggest problems which
is how will we sustainably
generate energy in this new world where
energy usage will only go up from here
how do you approach the monumental
challenge of innovating renewable energy
during a 13-year project that concluded
in 2020
the makani team set out to take on the
challenge using technology
inspired by kitesurfing i'm priyanka a
developer advocate with google cloud
and i wanted to learn more about how
google cloud played a part
in the search for a new kind of
wind-powered energy
how were the kites tested and simulated
to further the project's progress
the team gave me the inside scoop on how
google cloud powered the simulations and
data processing
for the energy kites i am very excited
to find out how the kite simulation logs
were collected
processed analyzed and visualized to
make continuous improvements to these
guides
but before we jump into the technical
background let's see a quick
overview of how wind powered kites
actually work
[Music]
makani's energy kite was an aerodynamic
wing tethered to a ground station
to begin flight the kite used rotors to
hover vertically in the air
once at full tether length the kite
transitioned into crosswind flight
flying in vertical loops as the kite
flies
the rotors are spun by the wind
generating
electricity that is sent down the tether
to the grid
the kite's path is managed by the flight
computer
which guides the kite even in turbulent
winds and
safely returns it to the ground station
so those are the basics but to
understand how the makani energy kite
worked it is helpful to look at how the
mechanics of a traditional wind turbine
translated
into a crosswind kite the blade on a
wind turbine
redirects wind and creates one force
that pushes on the tower and another
that pushes the blade forward
the forward push of the blades turns a
generator to make power
the crosswind kite is like freeing a
blade from the tower
the freed blade now owing is able to
grab
more wind therefore making more power
than it could
when stuck to a tower the crosswind kite
grabs
more wind and generates more power for
the same size
wing from the wind turbine but with less
materials
[Music]
trying to extract power from the wind
and that's
what we would get closer to when we went
testing it's like the actual wind
the physical world where our technology
had to work well
so sometimes the challenges were it was
not windy enough and we were sitting
there waiting for wind and sometimes it
was too in thee
because flying a real kite is expensive
makani's team created
software that would simulate the kite
flying with
all the wing components and as much of
the physics they could simulate
close to a real kite they needed to run
the kite
at many different wind directions at
different altitudes
so they would generate hundreds of
different configurations to simulate the
flight
then these configurations were fed into
compute engine instances
that will run the kite simulations the
compute engine instances would be
created dynamically
to run these simulations generating log
files and reports
which would be then saved in google
cloud storage
and these compute engine instances would
eventually shut down themselves
saving cost and staying efficient after
that
the software engineers in the team would
pull these logs
and analyze them they would look for
issues red flags
things such as kite did not fly very
well there are some issues here
they would make new modifications and
then restart the simulation process
again
to go through the logs again and this
process keeps repeating
until the team felt confident that the
real kite will not crash under those
circumstances
once satisfied with the simulations they
would go to a real testing site such as
hawaii or norway to fly an actual kite
and as the kite is flying it would send
the logs to the command
center on ground once the flight is done
the logs are then sent to google cloud
storage for engineers to analyze again
they repeat the same process look at the
data
analyze it make modifications to those
configurations and then go back to the
first stage
run a bunch of simulations verify that
those changes
will make the kite fly better and won't
crash and will repeat the entire
cycle now let's talk about data analysis
the engineers had two ways to analyze
the data
manual lookup which is downloading the
file to their computer
load it into matlab or use a python
program and run their own
analysis scripts but with a project like
this
there needs to be a well-defined
consistent analysis that could run
over and over on all the flight data for
that
they built a data analytics front end on
app engine
where an engineer would submit a request
for all the logs in a particular time
range
and analyze them with these predefined
criterias
app engine will store the request into
cloud sql
and send it to pub sub messaging service
jenkins master will
pull the analysis request and distribute
the job to a bunch of compute engine
worker instances
these instances were always alive
waiting for requests to be sent
to them the worker would send a request
to cloud storage
for the log files for that specific date
and time range
process those logs for analysis produce
the results
and then store them back in cloud sql
and publish to app engine
essentially the makani team ran a bunch
of simulations
collected a ton of data and learned from
it then
they flew a real kite studied that data
and reiterated the process for the
next successful flight google cloud
played a critical role in this process
by providing them
a scalable infrastructure for
simulations and data analysis
while keeping them focused on the real
problem of harnessing wind energy
[Music]
though the makani team's journey has
drawn to an end
they set up a portfolio of open source
resources
including technical reports videos
documentation
patents code and more check out the
makani website to get a full
overview if you are interested in
learning more about makani's journey
they also shared a full-length
documentary
which we have linked below makani's goal
was to harness wind energy
and google cloud played a huge role in
providing the resources needed
to do just that without worrying about
the infrastructure
scale and data processing in this behind
the scenes series we will continue to
explore
how google cloud powers incredible
projects such as makani
and i'm looking forward to taking this
journey with you all
you